he's also accomplishment the Luxembourg
presidency had placed on the agenda a
point concerned the social situation in
road transport or the Luxembourg
presidencies gathered together the
discussions we took noted everything
that was said and we intend to produce a
document that we are going to pass on to
the Commission so that everything that
was said today can be taken account
office in the road package next year and
we talked about road safety the midterm
review of the white paper next year will
perhaps be a good opportunity to tackle
road safety issues once again I think we
all when we address social issues as the
first item on the agenda we really got
very clear message that market opening
has to walk hand in hand with with
progressive social solutions as well and
I'm glad that here we have a consensus
and now you can always look for
solutions that lead towards as I
mentioned before comprehensive covering
hensive solutions in different modes
blue League lamasa let the new
regulation on open internet and
abolition of roaming charges has just
edited to forces the crucial step to
complete the digital market which is
very important to Luxembourg to the
presidency and to the citizens the
European citizens as well because
roaming charges constitute one of the
most striking gaps in the digital market
and the regulation has enabled us to
eliminate these surcharges by June 2017
which is a major step forward with his
two successes we have managed to bring
the Union closer to its citizens we
completed negotiations with the European
Parliament on the directive on the
network and information security this is
a decisive step which enables us to
adopt a coordinated approach to
cybersecurity either via law throughout
Europe by promoting cooperation amongst
the Member States and creating security
obligations and notification obligations
for the stakeholders providing key
services access for people living with
disabilities work almost at a trial log
stage on this proposal and next year we
expect to see a breakthrough in the
trial log so that we have European
legislation on access to public service
websites